today on the Matt Walsh show the media
continues to openly root against the
United States which is something of
course they've been doing for decades
but it's been even more grotesque and
getting more grotesque by the day during
this crisis also five headlines
including a whole bunch of congressmen
who apparently don't don't understand
how to wear a mask and don't understand
why we are wearing masks and I think
need to be reported to the various
snitch lines for their violations of
social distancing and today in our daily
cancellation I will be canceling
everyone just everybody it's time it
needs to be done and I'll explain why
all of that is coming up but first a
word from LifeLock you know you need to
be prepared and if if recent events have
taught us anything is that you need to
be prepared in general the Boy Scouts
taught us that you know so we should
have been listening need to be prepared
for it for any eventualities there are
some people who seem like they're
prepared for anything you know if you
have a if you have a cut they've got a
band-aid ready to go if you need a
battery they've got all the multiple
sizes on hand but if they're worried
about identity theft and only monitoring
their credit they may not be as prepared
as they think they are breaches seem
like they're happening more these days
and with your breached information like
your name your social security number
and more criminals can commit identity
theft they can wreak all kinds of havoc
in your life that's why life lock sees
sees more threats like someone taking
out a payday loan in your name stuff
like you know that you wouldn't be able
to find on your own and then they alert
you to possible suspicious activity and
if you end up having an identity theft
issue god forbid then you'll have an a
dedicated identity restoration
specialist who is just a phone call away
and ready to take care of things for you
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but with breaches on the rise
doesn't it make sense to be prepared
just join LifeLock today and save up to
25% off your first year go to LifeLock
comm slash walsh that's a it's LifeLock
comm slash walsh LifeLock dot-com slash
walsh to save 25% off all right by the
way before I get going I wanted to just
mention one thing and I don't know if
I'm alone in this
among people who are glasses but I've
discovered that if you don't wear
glasses you can't relate to this okay
because you're not you're not in the
victim group you know that we're in as
visually impaired individuals but
apparently you can't wear glasses and
also a face mask and still be able to
see because the glasses get fogged up so
I try to go to the store got the face
mask on and I'm wandering around the
store bumping into things because my
glasses are getting fogged up because as
you're breathing the air from your mouth
goes up into your glasses and causes
this fog situation and so now I'm
starting to think of all the doctors and
surgeons that you see that wear glasses
I mean I've had a ghillie surgery last
year and my doctor wore glasses and now
I'm realizing that he couldn't see a
thing he was doing the entire time and
I'm just now realizing this and I wish I
didn't know it to be honest with you so
if there's any solution to that that
you're aware of as a glass any any glass
glasses wearing people if you've
discovered a solution to the fogging of
the glasses please let me know for my
own my own safety and the safety of
those around me okay well it's not news
I suppose that the media routes against
America especially in recent years as
and and especially now that America is
governed by a man that they despise with
every fiber of their being
but this spectacle of the media rooting
against us has been especially grotesque
and outrageous and traitorous traitorous
at least in a moral sense
during this coronavirus crisis I think
and it makes you think back to the very
early days of 9/11 I've been thinking
about this a lot and it's like you know
we we've always talked about right after
9/11 there was at least it seemed at the
time there was a very real national
unity for a while in last it was
temporary but even the media for the
most part Democrats Republicans most
everybody for a time a brief glorious
time in history there seemed to be a
real sense of common purpose and
everybody was on the same side for at
least a few days
well we never had that with this and I
wonder if we're even capable of it
anymore I think I think probably not I
think we're at a point in in our in our
in our in our culture where we're not
capable of that kind of unity even when
we're facing a common threat so I want
to talk about just one example of the
media rooting against us and celebrating
seeming to celebrate our in their minds
demise and in fact before I do that just
one other really egregious recent
example that I happen to see online when
I was when I was yesterday this is a
woman named Samira Khan who is a foreign
policy analyst and here she is now
follow this exchange on Twitter Samira
says sick of the following kovat 19
talking points one it's a hoax to
severity and death count equals
exaggerated three China is to blame feel
free to add to the list than some random
guy responds China has to be blamed
babe's isn't that obvious then Samir
says babe's puke face emoji no I don't
know what your crap media is telling you
but the world should be thanking China
for their efforts now I don't know if
this woman lives in America or not I
think she does but that was so egregious
that I had to mention it thanking China
we should be thanking China for their
efforts their efforts in starting and
lying about and thereby causing the
uncontrollable spread of a deadly virus
we should thank them for that anyway so
on to the AP here's the AP s tweets of
their article the caption says it wasn't
supposed to be this way America was the
greatest of all nations with can-do
spirit in its DNA but now it leads only
in kovat 19 deaths what's gone wrong and
then the title of the article
coronavirus shakes the conceit of
American exceptionalism the byline is
Calvin Woodward wrote it but then it
says that lauren near guard in
washington Ted Anthony in Pittsburgh and
AIA Batra in Dubai contributed to this
report so a reporter who doesn't live in
America contributed to a report about
America is not exceptional so that's
that's just great reading from the
article says when the corona virus
pandemic came from distant lands the
United States it was met with cascading
failures and incompetence in
competencies by a system that exists to
prepare protect prevent and cut citizens
a check in a national crisis
the molecular Menace posed by the new
corner virus has shaken the conceit of
American exceptionalism like nothing big
enough to see with your own eyes a
nation with unmatched power brazen
ambition and aspirations through the arc
of history to be humanity's shining city
upon a hill cannot come up with enough
simple cotton swabs despite the wartime
manufacturing supply powers assumed by
President Donald Trump that it continues
on for effective diagnostic testing
crucial or an infectious outbreak look
abroad to United Arab bid to the United
Arab Emirates or Germany or New Zealand
which jumped to test the masses before
many were known to be sick or to south
korean exceptionalism tapped by
Maryland's Republican governor Larry
Hogan who accepted a plane load of
500,000 testing kits from South Korea to
make up for the u.s. shortfall simple
gloves complicated ventilators special
lab chemicals test swabs mask down face
shields hospital beds emergency payouts
from the government benefits for idled
worker workers each has been subject to
chronic chronic shortages spot shortages
calcified bureaucracy or some
combination okay and then it goes on
from there I can't read the whole thing
it's very quite lengthy now here's the
thing and you get this a lot for the
medium many of the points being raised
that I just read there and throughout
the article are not wrong it would
certainly be hard to argue that the
response from our country has been
stellar exactly and we were caught
unprepared and we shouldn't have been
unprepared and we have government
agencies that are supposed to be keeping
us prepared for this sort of thing like
the CDC and they do their job and many
of the other things that this article
points out are true
yes but they marshal all of these facts
in service to an ideological point and
then they cover it in a falsehood the
ideological point is that American
exceptionalism is just a conceit and a
false one and the falsehood
that we lead only in kovat 19 deaths
which implies obviously first of all
that we don't lead in any other category
which is not true but it's also untrue
that we lead in Cova 19 deaths that you
know the only way to get to that
statistic and the media has to know this
so which so when you when you've other
media constantly saying that we lis
didn't cover 19 deaths they have to know
that what they're saying is not true I
mean at best highly misleading but
really simply untrue yet they keep
saying it why do they keep saying it
well it's I mean it's almost like they
want it to be true or at least they want
us to believe that it's true and this is
what I'm talking about with rooting
against American so the only way to get
to that statistic the only way to
support the idea that we lead in deaths
is to do two extremely disingenuous
things one is to ignore population size
and to just do a straight-up comparison
between our total deaths and total
deaths in like New Zealand you know in
Denmark completely putting aside that
our population is many many many many
many times larger than those countries
so obviously we're gonna have more
deaths then you also have to ignore
total cases and of course we don't know
the total cases for any country and the
fact that we don't know that is a
problem because it also means that the
death toll is probably a lot lower than
we think but still obviously if you have
more cases you're gonna have more deaths
now obviously America is gonna have more
cases than a place like New Zealand
because we have a lot more people and
also we have a lot more people coming
here from other parts of the country are
to the world now according to USA Today
and this is in an article meant to
basically debunk Trump's claim that our
death rate is low compared to other
countries which is actually true that it
is low compared to many other countries
but if the process of trying to debunk
that claim the USA Today USA Today did
admit quote when compared only to the 10
countries with the most cases the u.s.
ranks as the second lowest mortality
rate as a percentage of total cases that
means eight of those countries hit
hardest by the corner of ours have
higher mortality rates than the US well
that's the honest comparison to make you
have to look at other countries that got
a ton of cases because they have larger
populations in most cases and
and also because maybe they have more
people coming into their countries and
then or you could look at deaths per
100,000 people or poor a million people
and when you do that so you're looking
at it more a per capita basis and when
you do that we're nowhere near the top
of the list in fact I don't even think I
don't think we even make it into the
into the top 10 when you look at it that
way and then in order to claim that
America leads and deaths you also have
to take China at its word on its death
count and you have to assume that a
country like India with a billion plus
people claiming only 700 deaths you have
to assume that that number is accurate
and not to say that India would be lying
about their def khmer be they would be
but also you have to think in a country
like India they may not have
successfully counted all the people who
actually died of this illness so but you
have to put that to the side you have to
assume that in India with with with one
point I think it's 1.3 billion people
only 700 of died of coronavirus and
China's being honest so you assume all
of that and then and then even then you
don't get to America having the most
cases now none of this again is to say
that our response in America has been
good it hasn't in my view but the media
wants us to believe that it's the worst
and that we're the hardest hit and that
we're the most incompetent and you can
practically see the gleeful smiles when
you read this stuff this is what happens
when you buy into the narrative that
America is the villain of the world and
then when bad stuff happens to your
country if that's if you've bought into
a narrative that your country is the
villain bad stuff happens to your
country and then I guess you feel pretty
good about it which is seem it seems
that that's the case for a lot of people
in the media ok let's move on to
headlines number one NFL Draft was last
night they had to do it all virtual
which meant that Roger Goodell for the
first time ever wasn't booed every time
he spoke the NFL Commissioner usually at
these events he gets up there for the
first round anyway to announce the
people
who
drafted to the various teams and every
time he goes takes a stage he's booed
but he that didn't happen this time I
watched a little bit of it mainly
because I'm desperate for sports like
like most red-blooded American men so
I'll even sit and watch guys on a webcam
list the names of players who've been
drafted that's how desperate I am for
some kind of live sporting event but it
was kind of awkward because they had
webcams in all of the homes of the
projected first-round draft picks so we
could see their excitement in real time
as they learned that they were drafted
which had to be annoying you know I felt
I felt bad for those kids because this
is this is one of the biggest moments of
their lives the moment their life
changes the moment that all the years of
hard work pays off it's a very
significant profound beautiful moment
for them and and they've got a camera
shoved in their face so that millions of
people can watch and judge their
reaction as they learn the news now I
mean I think even like during holidays
or a birthday when I have to open
presents in front of other people and I
don't have a camera shoved in my face
well sometimes I do but I don't have
millions people watching but even that I
really hate opening presents in front of
other people it's why I don't like
holidays I would just I'd be in favor of
abolishing the gift-giving process
altogether because then I feel like I've
got all this pressure I have to be
excited about every gift that I open and
I'm not an excitable person so even if
I'm very excited about a gift like I
could get a gift I could open a gift and
it could be a treasure chest full of
gold bars you know adding up to like
three million dollars in value and my
reaction to that would be something like
oh cool wow really cool thank thanks to
us so much yeah I really I thank you
really cool that'd be my reaction that
would also be my reaction if you give me
socks either way just how I am
so I felt bad for these kids because I
think I think a lot of them are sort of
the same as me not not as excitable and
so you're watching their reactions and
many of them do not appear excited at
all and so it's very awkward especially
the guy that was drafted by the Jaguars
here was his reaction
[Applause]
well there you see happiness all the way
around it and just so you know obviously
it makes a lot of sense because the
Jaguars moved on from Jalen Ramsay last
year they clearly needed help at the
quarterback position now in fairness I
think he was actually overcome with
emotion there and and and so so I think
he was excited but it did kind of look
like he was mourning over being drafted
by the Jaguars and I wouldn't blame him
for that if he was by the way his
reaction was judged by jerks like myself
as I am doing to him right now
what I hate when people do to me so
moving on dr. Scott Gottlieb on Twitter
says says this study of 318 outbreaks in
China found transmission occurred out of
doors and only one involving just two
cases most occurred in home or public
transport raises ki chance for states to
move service outdoors religious gym
classes restaurants etc now this this is
you know in spite of this you still got
morons panicking over people going to
the beach and as I've been saying all
along yeah even though I'm not a doctor
it seemed obvious to me that the beach
is probably one of the safest places in
the world you can be right now fresh air
open air lots of win lots of lots of
circulation there it's it's it's hot
it's sunny just doesn't seem like the
best environment for a for a virus to be
transmitted you know if I were a virus
and I wanted to be transmitted I would
not shoot and I could choose anywhere I
would not choose a beach I would choose
a public transportation and in lieu of
that if if not that at least yes being
being being a I think the best-case
scenario would be you know being cooped
up in a house with other people now
that's a great opportunity for a
transmission so yeah I think this could
be a solution for a lot of businesses
that are apprehensive about opening when
they're allowed to open if you can move
you know move the move it outside have
people sitting outside as much as
possible
churches doing outdoor services and as
we move into the warmer months in the
summer and everything I think that could
be a great solution might not be
possible for every
in every restaurant of course but where
it is possible I think that could be a
good way of doing it let's see number
three the mayor of a city in Japan is
under fire for saying that men should do
the grocery shopping because women take
too long and they clog up the lanes at
the store by dawdling around he said is
what he said quote women take a longer
time grocery shopping because they
browse through different products and
way out which option is best men quickly
grab what they're told to buy so they
won't linger at the supermarket that
avoids close contact with others I think
this is obviously true and people are
upset of course because they're always
going to get upset when you make any
sort of observation about women that
appears to be less than flattering you
know if you if you dare say anything
about women that is that is short of
bowing before them and worshiping them
anything short of that and it's highly
offensive but this is obviously true it
seems to me it certainly in my
experience of both being a man and a
husband and also going to grocery stores
and also just what I know about men men
are all about efficiency okay men are
going to be more efficient in pretty
much everything if you want efficiency
go to a man whether it's grocery
shopping whether it's telling a story
about what happened to them during the
day whether it's anything man's gonna be
more efficient now that's not to say
that the man is always gonna do a better
job because yeah I would say that women
if you got all the time in the world
then then yeah you want the woman to do
the grocery shopping because she's she
is she's gonna be thinking very hard
about what she's buying she's going to
be finding the best deals you know and
all of that but we're in a position
right now where we just need to get in
and get out and if you need someone to
get in get it done and get out that's
you need men you need men for that so
that's now when I'm at the grocery store
I've got my list and I'm just going
through the aisles as fast as I can you
know grabbing it I don't even look at it
hardly I just grab first thing I see
first version you know if there's
something on the list that says you know
mayonnaise or whatever I'm just grabbing
the first jar that I see I'm not
sitting there now if MIT was my wife
she's gonna sit there she's gonna look
at all the different versions of
mayonnaise you think you know what's the
healthiest what's the cheapest can I get
a deal here what brand do we like the
most
you know this jars a little bit bigger
than that jar is that a better deal than
that one oh do I want do I want
mayonnaise it has olive oil flavoring or
do you know do it we don't have time for
that right now
maybe in the future but right now you
just got to grab the mayonnaise and so I
think that obviously you need men need
men for that number four I'm going to be
putting a report into de Blasio's social
distancing snitch line where your report
violations of social distancing rules
because I saw a new a New Yorker a New
York resident flagrantly violating
social distancing policies and I think
this needs to be reported to a de Blasio
ASAP on behalf of my constituents in the
Bronx in Queens New York's 14th
congressional district the most impacted
district in America calling people
losing their families every day it is a
joke when Republicans say that they have
urgency around this bill the only folks
that they have urgency around are folks
like Ruth's Chris Steakhouse and Shake
Shack those are the people getting
assistance in this bill you are not
trying to fix this bill for mom and pops
and we have to fight to fund hospitals
fighting to fund testing that is what
we're fighting for in this bill it is
unconscionable if you had urgency you
would legislate like rent was due on May
1st and make sure that we include rent
and mortgage relief for our constituents
so there's a OC inside around other
people holding her masks in her hand
while she shouts I I think taking the
mask off to shout taking the mask off in
order to shout seems like it really
defeats the purpose of the masks in fact
you probably mainly need the masks for
the shouting part like you'd be better
off not wearing it for any other part
and just putting it on for the shouting
because that's when the spittle is gonna
be going all over the place but that
that's like that's like if you have a
mask and you're walking around to the
store or something and as soon as you
have to COFF you just pull the mask down
to cough and then you put the mask back
up it defeats the purpose it reminds me
of fact I was at Walmart the other day
and there
a woman I'm not I'm not joking she was
walking through the store and she had
pulled her mask down to sing she was
singing with her mask pulled down in
Walmart and I almost did report her as
much as I'm against snitching and I
believe snitches get stitches and for a
good reason
I almost reporter but not really because
of the the mask thing is it's more than
she was happy at Walmart and you're just
you're not supposed to be that happy at
Walmart it's not a place for happiness
but anyway this was a common theme
actually in Congress none of these
people who lead our country
apparently understand how to wear a mask
or why we wear them so let's take a look
at a couple more examples of these
pictures here these are people that have
masks at various different places on
their face but not really covering the
mouth and the nose which is what it's
supposed to do and then the worst of all
is this this is a very important piece
of legislation so we come to the floor
our important piece of legislation so we
come to the floor with such heartache
which just sorrow about those who have
lost their lives and their loved ones
those who are suffering from the virus
assault
now that's Nancy Pelosi mask off wipes
her nose and then touches the podium
that a bunch of other Congress people
are going to be using that's a that's an
that is a terrorist attack really is
what that is that's a that's a national
security emergency what just happened
there she could have unleashed a deadly
pathogen into into the the halls of the
US Congress I think she needs to be
arrested immediately for this and many
other reasons finally a report from the
CBS affiliates in New York says MTA
subway conductors say trains are
filthier than ever
amid coronavirus pandemic it says the
subways are only supposed to be for
essential workers during the corona
virus pandemic the conductor's say the
trains are filthier than ever the MTA
says that only about 5% of its regular
ridership is taking the subway
and that's made up of people who work in
hospitals grocery stores in every other
essential service but conductors say the
subway has become a homeless shelter and
social distancing is near impossible
cell phone video shows subway cars lined
with people passed out using shoes as
pillows not wearing masks trash piled in
shopping carts urine feces so and so
forth everywhere and this is what's
happening in the in the subway system in
New York we see how in this has been the
case all on the the it's pretty clear
that public transportation New York
subway system was a vector of disease
it's basically a disease transmission
system you want to talk about efficient
getting the virus from one corner of the
city to the other if you're wondering
why one of the reasons why New York has
had it so much worse than every other
place in America it's this when you've
got this disease transmission system
shooting the disease all over the place
and then you've got you know like 20,000
people per square mile living in this
densely packed place it's not hard to
see why that why they've had such a hard
time of it okay now let's move to our
daily cancelation for a daily
cancellation I'm gonna be canceling
everybody you know what I'm everybody's
canceled everybody and I'll tell you why
there have been headlines in the media
like this from NBC and it says Trump
suggests injection of disinfectant to
beat coronavirus and clean the lungs so
Trump suggests injection and then tweets
like this from a Biden staffer it says
this election is a choice between two
competing visions for America one that
says you should drink bleach to cure
viruses and another that says do not
drink bleach and then we've got
indignant fat checks from conservative
sites like Breitbart fact-check know
Trump didn't propose injecting people
with disinfectant so this is what's
going back and forth okay here's what
Trump actually said let's go to the tape
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous whether it's ultraviolet or
just very powerful light and I think you
said that hasn't been checked but you're
gonna test it and then I said supposing
you brought the light inside the body
you can which
you can do either through the skin or in
some other way
and I think you said you're gonna test
that too
sounds interesting right and then I see
the disinfectant where it knocks it out
in a minute
one minute and is there way we can do
something like that by injection inside
work or almost a cleaning because you
see it gets in the lungs and it does a
tremendous number along so it'd be
interesting to check that so that you're
gonna have to use medical doctors with
but it sounds it sounds interesting to
me
okay so Trump didn't propose or urge
injecting disinfectant he certainly
didn't say we should drink bleach day
that that was never brought up but he
did clearly and we all heard it you
heard the tape that's that it that there
it is in context he did ask whether we
could inject disinfectant into the body
to clean the body he did ask that he did
bring that up I didn't urge it didn't
propose it didn't tell people to run out
and do it he certainly didn't say go go
uh you know grab some Lysol or Clorox or
something and inject it into your veins
he didn't say that
but he did ask about it and so we see
here a familiar dynamic and this is a
this is a dynamic that I I'm really
tired of III love it in fact and that is
where Trump says something dumb and
let's face it this was very very dumb
and then the media twists it into
something even more dumb and then
conservative media comes along and
righteously you know calls the media to
task calls them godforsaken liars and
explains that Trump didn't say that dumb
thing he said a slightly less dumb thing
you liars he didn't say that dumb thing
I mean he did say something pretty dumb
but it wasn't that dumb and I'm just so
tired of the whole thing yeah the media
is lying about it but I can't muster the
energy to be that angry at them when he
did in fact say something very stupid
and so I kind of think he's the
president's he's an adult
maybe don't say the stupid stuff just a
thought I don't know your
you're doing a press conference the
middle of a crisis maybe maybe for once
think a little bit before you speak
maybe and if you're not going to I don't
really feel like go to the mat for you
fifty times a freaking week to explain
that the dumb crap you said is not quite
as dumb as I just don't feel like doing
that so many people in conservative
media have spent years doing this this
has become their entire job as doing
this is just explaining every dumb thing
that he says and right
that to me is annoying it's also
annoying of course at the media would
lie about I mean the idea that he would
propose drinking bleach it's totally
crazy and there is a significant
difference between asking can we do this
or speaking about hypothetically and
urging it and the really stupid thing
for the media is if they could just
stick to the truth the truth is pretty
bad in and of itself and if they stuck
to the truth then the story would remain
the dumb thing Trump said which is what
they would prefer instead of the story
becoming them lying about it because of
course what conservatives want to do is
they want to they never want the story
to be the dumb thing that Trump said
they want the story to be the media
lying about it and that I mean that's no
secret many conservatives of media they
would like to deflect every time Trump
said something dumb they're looking for
any reason to deflect it and the media
always comes along and gives them a
reason to so it's just stupidity all
across the board and that's why I say
everybody is canceled Trump is canceled
the media's canceled conservative
media's canceled
I'm canceled you're canceled your pet
goldfish is canceled everyone and
everything is canceled period okay
that's the only way we could be free of
this let's go to some emails before we
do you know what is not canceled The
Daily wire and our tumblers specifically
in fact you get 2 of our tumblers if you
become a daily wire remember on top of
that you get many other benefits as well
you get an ADD free website experience
access to all of our live broadcast show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show access to the mailbag and
now exclusive election insight op-eds
from ben shapiro delaware members also
get to ask us questions during backstage
and you get to participate in our
all-access live shows which are a lot of
fun as well so that's two leftist um
Tumblr's leftist ears tumblr it's not
leftist tumblers I should clarify these
are not tumblers for left us they're
tumblers for the tears of leftist when
you become a daily wire insider plus our
all-access member and you get ten
percent off with coupon code Walsh just
head on over to daily wire.com slash
subscribe that's daily wired.com /
subscribe coupon code walsh and you get
the rarest of all beverage vessels times
two let's see this is from madison says
good afternoon i just finished listening
to your program and felt compelled to
comment after hearing the stories about
weird homeschooled kids in college I
wanted to refute the idea that these
people are somehow less or strange
because of it I'm kerfing I'm currently
in college and help mentoring help
mentor income incoming freshmen I can't
speak okay I can't read or speak and I
went to public school so what does that
tell you don't blame this on
homeschooling i mentor incoming freshmen
as they transition from high school back
in August I've met a woman named
Penelope who'd been homeschooled from
middle school and she was one of the
nicest people I'd ever met except for
not knowing what a scantron was what a
freak what a freak doesn't what a
scantron is weird oh she was no
different from all the other students
and proved to be kinder and more
intelligent than a lot of incoming
freshmen she has been accepted into the
mentoring program and will be helping
other students next year it seems to me
that all these stories are coming out
now because people are jealous
homeschool students are ahead of the
curve and are doing better with the
transition to online than most other
students that I have helped
I appreciate what you do on your show
and thank you for being one of the few
people in the media who are keeping
their heads on yeah and I want to read
that because we were getting all these
anecdotes from people that I did read
and you know in fairness trying to get
both sides of it but anecdotes from
people talking about the weird
homeschoolers and so and I've responded
to that I'm not gonna respond to it
again but all these people saying I am
you know this home schoolers and they're
so weird I don't know what I'm not
saying they don't exist but but what
I've met a lot of home schoolers and for
the most part these are really
impressive people so what what home
schoolers are you meeting exactly if
you've never met any of the really
impressive ones so I agree with
that's been my experience as well this
is from Kyle says hi Matt I enjoy
hearing you talk about the arguments for
God especially the arguments for God
that you don't like most apologists
aren't willing to do this so your
honesty and critical thinking is
refreshing I've never heard you talk
about the transcendental argument for
God and would love to hear your take on
it I know you're not a fan of the
presuppositional approach so I think I
know how you'll feel about this I'm not
that's true
if you aren't familiar Tagg
transcendental argument forgot it goes
like this
sorry I lifted this from Wikipedia just
because it's a short explanation one God
is a necessary precondition for logic
and morality because these are
immaterial yet real universals two
people depend upon logic and morality
showing that they depend upon the
universal immaterial and abstract
realities which could not exist in a
materialist universe but presupposed
presumes the existence of an immaterial
and absolute God 3 therefore God exists
if he didn't we could not rely upon
logic reason morality and other absolute
universals and could not exist in a
materialist universe where these are no
at where there are no absolute standards
or an absolute lawgiver
or two been going back this is now in
the back to Kyle's phrasing or to put it
in the terms that Matt slick these are
an apologist puts it 1 we we have only
two possible options by which we can
explain something and one of those
options is is removed by default the
other option is verified since it is
impossible to negate both of the only
two existing conditions I think there
was a word missing there if we have only
two possible options by which we can
explain something and one of those
options is removed then by default the
other option is the one that we have to
go with to God either exists or does not
exist there is no third option 3 if the
no God position atheism clearly fails to
account for logical absolutes from its
perspective then it is negated and the
other option is verified for atheism
cannot account for the necessary
preconditions for intelligibility namely
the existence of logical absolutes
therefore it is invalidated as a viable
option for counting for them and the
only other option God exists is
validated back to Kyle I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this Thanks ok that's
interesting I haven't given this line of
argumentation much thought I
vaguely familiar with it so just off the
top of my head here I will say that I
appreciate what the argument is trying
to do it's trying to prove God prove God
right by using logic and most apologetic
arguments are not actually trying to
prove God because they can't because you
know they are most apologetic here are
evidential arguments and an evidential
argument the problem with an evidential
argument and and i and i like many of
the evidential arguments but they could
only go so far that they are limited
because there's always going to be
different ways of interpreting the
evidence and if you're following the
rules of philosophy you can't make an
evidential argument even a strong one
like fine-tuning which i think is very
strong evidential argument forgot but
you can't make that and then say that
based on that you know for a fact that
god exists you can only say and this is
how you know someone like William Lane
Craig is gonna phrase and he's going to
say that God is more plausible than not
based on that but then of course that
leaves open philosophically you know in
the in the gyms in the by the rules of
the argument you have to leave open the
possibility that there is no God and of
course if you're an apologist or if
you're a Christian in general you would
like to have arguments that don't leave
that open and so you want an argument
right that is that's gonna 100% prove
logically that God exists so that's what
this argument is trying to do that's
what the ontological argument is trying
to do I appreciate the attempt I but I
don't think this argument is successful
he doesn't strike me as successful the
first problem is the premise that God is
a necessary precondition for logic and
morality so that you know the issue is
no obviously I agree with it but that's
a highly contentious premise I mean it's
almost like trying to make an argument
and your first premise is something like
I don't know this maybe isn't a great
analogy but it's like if your first
premise was the Bible is the most
important book ever written if that was
like the first premise of an argument
you were making for God now
agree to the Bible's the most important
book ever written I think it's a fairly
easy thing to prove or at least to argue
in favor of but it is controversial it's
not self-evident you you do have to
argue for it so you can't really start
there you got to start further back to
get there and I think something like God
is a necessary precondition for logic
and morality that's a highly contentious
program is it isn't it's an argument in
fact in and of itself that you have to
provide evidence for you can't just
assert it because first of all you know
you could rebut this by saying well
morality doesn't exist at least in an
objective sense there is no objective
morality so even if God is a necessary
precondition for it so what because
objective morality doesn't exist and I
think for an atheist when it comes to
the moral argument which i think is
another strong argument for God but with
the moral argument now there are some
atheists like like sam harris who will
try to argue that no objective morality
does exist without god and he can make
an interesting argument I don't find it
persuasive I think the better are you
the stronger argument for an atheist
perspective is just to say no there is
no objective morality okay I mean I I
think we kind of pretend
in order to make society function we
have to do things like not kill each
other and we have to punish people who
do just a society can function but
there's no reason to say that it's
objectively wrong to kill somebody
that's the route some atheists will go
it's a little bit I could see why they
wouldn't want to defend that because of
the implications of it but in terms of
an argument that's gonna be stronger so
anyway they could always say that and I
think that's going to undermine your
premise and then the idea that logical
absolutes can't exist without God
strikes me as somewhat unintelligible I
mean a logical absolute what's a logical
absolute a logical absolute is something
like a is a or a is not B therefore B is
not a those are logical statements they
are logical absolutes why couldn't that
be true without God I mean you might
argue that we couldn't come to know the
logical absolutes without God and that
gets into the
question of consciousness where did
consciousness come from but then again
you're going back to the consciousness
argument which I've already said I think
is maybe one of the strongest argument
forgot maybe the strongest but that's
really the argument it's about the
argument of consciousness so you got to
go all the way back there but Ken
logical absolutes exist you know if
there was no God and the universe just
existed would a still be a sure I don't
see why it wouldn't be and then there's
the issue that I guess a Christian
apologists you know if you're a
Christian apologist you're making this
argument you would want it to prove the
Christian God I would imagine and but it
doesn't really prove the Christian God
it just at best if if the argument is
successful it proves some kind of God
the problem is you know I could use Matt
Slick's formulation and I could use it
to prove any God right couldn't I so I
could say Brahma is the Hindu god so
couldn't I say if the no Brahma position
atheism clearly fails to account for
logical absolutes from its perspective
than it is negated and the other option
is verified atheism cannot account for
the necessary preconditions for
intelligibility namely the existence
will be the existence of logical
absolutes
therefore it is invalidated and the only
other option Brahma exists is validated
I don't see why I couldn't do that by
this logic I could prove Brahma I could
prove Vishnu I could prove Zeus Poseidon
you know anybody and maybe that's okay
because the argument is only trying to
establish some kind of God it's only
trying to get you to get you to that
point and if it could get you to that
point that's pretty significant in and
of itself I would think but you still
have a lot of work out still in front of
you to do and so but but anyway
I don't think that the argument gets you
to that point I don't think it I don't
think it really achieves a liftoff
because of the problems with the
premises that's a thing more about it
though it's an interesting as I said III
think this is good for apologists to be
doing to be thinking in terms of logical
arguments as well as evidential
arguments but I don't know if this one
really works thanks for that though
thank you that question always
interesting and have a great weekend
everybody Godspeed the Matt Walsh show
is produced by Sean Hampton executive
producer Jeremy boring our supervising
producers are Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
and our audio is mixed by Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't defended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we'll
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there